well my name is Spanish Mishra and I'm a
writer and I've just published this book
called in Topanga history of the present
which is essentially about the global
craziness that we see today every time
we pick up a newspaper demagogues
terrorists various far-right political
movements on the rise everywhere and
it's an attempt to understand this
particular phenomena historically and in
other ways as well can you tell a little
bit more about what is going on in terms
of the age of anger in India well it was
what actually made me want to write this
book it was the arrival in 2014 of a man
who should ideally be in prison and he
became the prime minister of this
country and he's now the most powerful
Prime Minister this country has had in
decades so that made me think that we
need to analyze this phenomenon slightly
more deeply than say journalistic
analysis that we need to go back to
history we need to look at how
demagogues in other countries have
pledged what kind of false promises they
offered to the waters to the masses at
large and how they able to acquire power
and hold on to it so in many ways this
book is prompted by my Indian experience
and while I was writing it Moody's or
people like Modi started to appear in
different parts of the world and again I
saw people falling for succumbing to
strongmen who they thought would deliver
to them on the promises that various
ruling classes had made in the past in
the recent past and and they're not
delivered you know in one sense I still
am loyal to an Enlightenment one
enlightenment idea which is that
individuals still have it in their
capacity to go to ku to do good and that
is the kind of power that I can still
trust today everything else the power of
corporations the power of government
that is something to be distrusted
especially at this moment and I think
we've seen what history has produced
ample evidence that's the kind of
expansion of power that is that is the
important project really in many ways
that is led to all kinds of calamities
all kinds of disasters it has
overwhelmed individual capacities to do
good and so I think what we need to
recover at this point is this is this
this only ideal which is individual
autonomy individual freedom the
individual capacity to do it I think
intellectuals which as a class really
start to emerge in the late 18th century
and I try to show in the book right from
the very beginning they are allied with
power often the despotic power with the
intention that their ideas might be
actualized might be realized by powerful
people might be institutionalized and I
think that's a very dangerous solution
and we've seen that over and over again
how intellectuals thinking that they can
shape political power and that their
ideas can be implemented fruitfully in
different parts of the world has led to
one disaster after another whether it's
new conservative intellectuals most
recently advocating the invasion of Iraq
and the imposition of democracy in the
Middle East or indeed any number of
modernization tourists running around
the world saying we have the right
formula for progress and development in
these societies and and uprooting large
numbers of people you know creating
essentially all the ingredients for
violent revolutions such as the tiny
soil Iran for instance after two or
three decades of bashed modernization by
naturally leads so I think we have to be
more suspicious of this figure the
intellectual and it's not easy for me to
say because you know I am one of those
people I criticize but I do think if we
need to move forward at this point all
of us and I know myself have to examine
our own assumption
what makes house on the Hudson with whom
you definitely sympathize the kind of
intellectual you think he's worthwhile
to reach
I think Edson was doing all the things
that I would ideally expect
intellectuals to do which is to
criticize their own work criticize their
own ideas and constantly reexamine their
assumptions you know here's a man who
comes to Europe from Russia wanting to
learn the secrets of progress from
Europe from European intellectuals and
quickly realizes that they have very
little to teach him that Russia needs to
follow its own particular path shaped by
its own history by its own circumstances
that this notion that everyone can
progress in the same sort of way the
kind of formula that the Europeans are
offering they are deeply deeply
defective so in many cases it's very
easy for someone like my son from India
to identify with Edison because he comes
from a country that is supposed to be
backward that's supposed to be
pre-modern
barbarous and he pawns mortality of some
kind or other and he realizes the
molarity that his own offer in 19th
century Europe is not what he wants and
if Russia does fall for it it would be
catastrophic for Russia the kind of
transformation thinking I'm thinking I'm
asking for is not something that can be
done by technocrats or by people in
Silicon Valley devising solutions for
general world improvement or uplift or
progress I think we have to examine our
own role in the world as it exists today
at level of individuals and then we have
to think about devising modes of
politics and economy which are not
fraught with the kind of political risks
that they've seen recently and also that
are environmentally sustainable you know
this is the biggest question that faces
us today of climate change whether
hundreds of millions of Indians and
Chinese can live at the same level of
material affluence that a few million
Europeans and
have enjoyed it remains an open question
and I think we can say safely the answer
is no at this point so is our progress
going to be environmentally sustainable
do we not need transformational thinking
about the good life what constitutes a
good life there are diverse ways of
conceiving it and I think we've been
told that there's only one and that
alone wants four transformational
thinking